Today,
the talks that Google series is featuring author Marcy Madden and her wife
Jeanette,
Scotty,
Jeanette Madden,
and uh,
Marcy Marcy recently wrote a book called just because my husband is a woman and
it's receiving five star ratings on Amazon.
Um,
I,
I'm really looking forward to her telling us her story,
her side of the story.
So I'm going to tell you a little bit about,
um,
a little bit about Marcy and Scotty before they come up on stage.
For those of you that are here,
uh,
in the room,
we've got free books.
Um,
so if you're nearby and you want to come,
please make your way over.
We've got at least 50 copies and um,
ping me afterwards if,
uh,
if you want extra,
if you want some,
we'll uh,
we'll send,
we'll send you the extra.
Marcy and Scotty are cofounders of Zuzu been press an independent publishing
company dedicated to creating a safer,
more loving world for Lgbtq?
I Aa plus people and their families.
They've been married for over 28 years.
I've known them for about 2020 plus of those years and each has a rich and
varied background as business owners and also in the production and TV world.
First,
Marcy,
Marcy went from managing several psychiatric offices in Marin and also has owned
several production companies.
She's been a director,
producer,
voiceover talent and wildlife rehabilitator and now she's an author.
Her new book was released on October 11th and it's entitled just because my
husband is a woman.
Marcy's side of the story.
Scotty who was just at Google last year giving her talk,
has sef,
has served in several capacities as well,
and the TV and film industry.
He's been a director.
She has been a director or a screenwriter and adventure documentary reality show
runner.
More recently,
Scottie has added speaker and author to her bio,
her memoir,
getting back to me from girl to boy to a woman in just 50 years is on Amazon's
Lgbtq biography best seller list and is in the process of being made into a TV
series.
Marcy and Scotty share intimate and pertinent stories about their real life
experience transitioning together.
Their story is both vulnerable and precious in our current times.
Like I said,
I've known Marcy and Scotty for over 20 years and it's a great privilege and
pleasure to bring them to the
talks at Google series.
And so I'd like to welcome first up Scottie,
Jeanette Madden.
Thank you,
Monica.
Right.
I'm out here to kind of set a little bit of context.
I'm the husband that Marcy spoke about.
What's important for you to know is that,
um,
for about three years solid every morning,
I would wake up at about 4:00 AM and I would pray to God for Marcy
and Marcy came.
I wasn't praying for her by name,
but I knew in the deepest fiber of my being that Marcy was out there and I just
wanted God to finally bring her to me.
I knew it as truly as I knew it,
that I was a woman.
I knew that despite what my body was telling me what everybody else in my life
was telling me,
that I was a woman.
I also knew that Marcy was out there.
So when Marcy says,
just because it's story goes a little bit deeper than that,
I'm so proud of her that she wrote this book.
But even more what I'm happy about is for you all to know now what I've always
known and that's how amazing Marcy is.
So I'll let her tell you the rest.
Thank you,
my love.
Thank you Monica so much.
It really is a pleasure to be here.
Being here with Scotty's book last year I had no idea that I would write a book.
Um,
and I guess I should tell you that it's obvious because of what Scotty just said
and the title of my book,
that there's not going to be a big Aha ending at the end of the talk.
You have that upfront.
So,
um,
the point of what I want to be here for today is,
to tell you the part that comes after the ellipses just because my husband's a
woman.
Dot.
Dot,
dot.
Marcy side of the story.
Uh,
and,
uh,
just a little bit of a warning here.
I don't know if any of you have ever thought that you might want to write a
book.
I think it's kind of a romantic idea that a lot of us share.
I certainly did,
but my problem was I thought I would never have a subject matter.
So just,
you know,
this is a warning to be careful what you wish for.
So yes,
my spouse,
Scotty is transgender.
Um,
we've been married almost 29 years,
20 of those years.
I thought I was married to my husband Scott.
Then one morning Scotty came with coffee early and blurted out the words that
she was a woman.
This was 20 years into our marriage and it wasn't planned.
It was just as if her emotions and her mouth took over.
It was not something that she ever really expected to reveal and um,
she really thought that she'd be going to her grave with this secret.
Nowadays we hear transgender,
that word quite a bit.
It's been in the media a lot.
We're very familiar with it.
Um,
it was not that familiar word to me,
especially in my early years,
but more people have stepped out of the darkness of their feelings and their
sadness and are,
are coming forward and speaking up.
Um,
of course we still really have a long way to go to find acceptance because we
can sense that I think in the political arena,
although after the elections from last night and the results,
I think we've got some positive movement forward again in that arena too.
So Scotty wrote her book about coming out and we don't really hear much about
what goes on when a person is married and what happens to the spouse when one
person wants to transition.
And statistically the most recent statistics that we have,
say that only 21% of marriages where someone transitions survive.
So when Scotty came out and we'd already been married for 20 years,
um,
what happened was when she would be going on her book signings in Tours,
uh,
and they'd come time for Q and a perhaps in one of those sessions,
some people would raise their hands and start addressing questions to me.
Like,
how did you do this and,
and why did you do it?
What,
what was it that prompted you to want to stay?
Um,
because a lot of times what they would do would be to put themselves in my
position and they just couldn't imagine it.
Um,
so just because my husband's a woman is,
is my story.
I'm going to give you a little bit of background of my history,
uh,
because it,
it goes way back into the dark ages.
But I think part of my upbringing was,
was a big arc in my whole journey of coming around to accepting,
uh,
what was happening in our lives.
Um,
I was born and raised in New England.
I'm very much the,
uh,
boarding school type of raising.
Um,
manners were a big thing in our household.
Both my parents had been to boarding.
Um,
I had,
uh,
I still have three brothers and even from the early days when people would ask
my mother how many kids she had,
her answer was,
I have four boys and one's a girl.
So as I look back on my life,
getting ready to write this book,
I started to see little hints along the way of things that I was learning that
either stood in my way for growth or actually helped me along the way.
But so it was expected.
I too went to boarding school.
I was there for three years.
Um,
and I think I'll tell you a little sidebar story just to show you again how far
I've had to come with his whole topic.
Um,
but I remember once sitting my roommate down after I'd been there for several
months and I said,
have I done something wrong?
Have I said something wrong to the other girls in the house?
They just seem like they're very standoffish and I feel like maybe I said
something I wasn't aware of that pissed them off.
And she said,
oh,
well.
And she shut the door to our bedroom and she sat on the bed opposite me and she
said,
well,
they think you're a lesbian.
And I went,
oh my God,
what's a lesbian?
So to say I was somewhat innocent is perhaps an understatement.
Um,
after boarding school,
I went to a two year college,
a woman's College in upstate New York,
and,
uh,
majored in an overseas program,
which took me to Geneva,
Switzerland for a year where I,
where I worked.
And,
um,
after that I came home in 1969 and I ended up moving to California starting out
here in the bay area.
And,
um,
for several years I was working for,
psychiatrists during those years.
Um,
there's a few stories about experiences with them and have that in,
um,
in my book.
Some of it was quite humorous and also another little breadcrumb that I'd
forgotten about until again,
I went back in my memory to think about what to write about in my book.
And I went,
oh wait.
I was kind of exposed to the subject of transgender back then,
but I hadn't even remembered it or put it together until looking back.
So after several years with the shrinks,
um,
I started in the production business.
I volunteered for a company and then I ended up being one of the owners of it.
It was a recording studio in San Francisco.
Um,
I had gotten married while I was still working for the psychiatrists.
Then when I went to work at the recording studio,
I fell in love with one of the partners in that.
And um,
so ended up in a divorce moving into marriage number two.
And as I look back,
what I realized was I really have always been looking for love.
I always had been and I felt like my parents had us storybook marriage.
My Dad would come home from work every night and find my mother first and give
her a movie dip kiss when he got home and they'd sit and have a cocktail
together and he would download his day.
And he really,
she was his muse and his confidant and his advisor.
And I just thought that's what a marriage should be like.
And so when mine weren't fitting that or when it felt like the feelings were
gone,
mostly probably just cause we settled into an everyday life.
I thought the love was gone.
And so that's how I would end up being attracted to somebody else and leave that
marriage and go into another one.
Um,
believe it or not,
I actually repeated the process again.
So I met this wonderful,
I'm very creative,
witty,
funny writer who was with one of the ad agencies who was our client.
And we started having lunches together and uh,
of course I thought,
well this is the one,
he's the one number two was not working out so well.
Uh,
the chinks in the armor we're definitely showing.
So I'm sure enough I broke off that marriage and entered number three and years
down the line of that marriage.
I think I hung in there for awhile.
Uh,
he was the one who broke it off.
So at least that was the little bit of a change in my pattern.
Um,
and he also had not been faithful.
So,
uh,
I realized I,
I probably just needed to really reevaluate what I was looking for and how I was
looking for it and needed some space to figure out who I really was.
So I lived on my own for awhile.
And then along came Scott.
I had no idea,
cause people ask me this all the time.
No,
I had no idea that Scott was anything but a creative,
wonderful,
thoughtful,
loving,
smart,
witty,
funny man who was,
um,
very much in love with me.
And so this one,
especially because I had taken the time,
I hadn't left from one relationship to another.
Um,
this just felt right and we fell together pretty much from day one,
except I get teased that I sent Scott home the first night because,
you know,
I didn't want to seem like I was too easy.
Um,
so at this point I want to read you a little bit from my book because I've
hinted that,
um,
surprisingly to myself,
there were some breadcrumbs along the way that we're maybe little clues of,
of what was really going on that I hadn't really seen for what they were.
So,
um,
this might tell you a little bit about
what that was like for me.
This is yours.
No,
I have,
I have like,
you know,
placeholders and everything.
I love your book.
Getting back to me.
Oh,
thank you.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Yeah,
I know.
I did that on purpose.
Okay.
Journey back with me to 1992 some of you probably weren't even born then,
so Scott and I were on a TV shoot in India for two weeks.
Being in India is like taking all the volume and color saturation knobs on your
viewing and listening devices and turning them up to the Max.
The colors are intensely vibrant and can burn your eyeballs.
The sounds are strange.
Symphony,
symphony of familiar and unfamiliar noises and the smells,
the smells,
smoke mixed with fragrant flowers,
some not so frequent elements.
Incense and teaming life.
We visited temples and teachers and Mountain Shrines and during the annual Mog
Mila,
we took a boat out onto the water at sunset,
at the sacred confluence of the three rivers,
the Ganges,
the Muna,
and the Saraswati where hundreds of people were waiting and dipping in the water
to be cleansed and to pray.
I took the opportunity to pray to the energy was thick with a vibrant,
with the vibration of something otherworldly,
something hallowed.
Since Scott and I were into yoga,
we felt deeply affected by being in the land where yoga was born.
We were so grateful.
Even giddy to be there though.
The host of the TV show was far from home including mentally and emotionally.
Scott and I felt very much at home.
We were curious to see and try everything despite the challenges of a small crew
with lots of equipment to lug around and despite the show's host hosts many
tantrums.
We thrived.
The crew were all good friends of ours,
family really.
We were all like kids in a new playground.
One day we visited a Jain temple near our hotel in Mount.
The temple was built into a hillside and it had no decoration or indication on
the outside that it was a temple.
This was to protect it from attack at wartime.
It just looked like part of the rocky hillside disguise so it could not be seen
from the air.
Once we stepped inside,
we were in a wonderland of carved marble.
It took the craftsman years and years to complete the work.
There was room after room of intricately carved marble and every inch of space
was done.
Floors,
ceilings,
walls and columns.
Often there were carvings within carvings,
one carved marble column within another.
It was as if the whole temple was made of the most intricate,
delicate,
white lace.
In some places you could look into an ante room and see other shapes and figures
that we're so tucked away it seemed we weren't even supposed to see them.
One such room had two huge lifesize marble marble elephants.
I could just see them through the lacy wall and door.
There was only cracked open and there were statutes of deities and saints
surrounding the outer circle of the temple.
They all had brightly painted eyes that when you stared at them drew you into a
deep and meditative state.
There was one such statue that completely had me mesmerized.
I just had to keep staring into those all knowing eyes.
I was filled with a feeling of warm love.
I felt completely connected,
completely one with that being and with everything around me and Scott was there
to seemingly in the same state when we compared our experiences.
Scott told me that his,
his case was locked on the statue.
He saw himself reach back to the middle of his shoulders,
grasp a zipper and unzipped from there and up over the top of his head until the
sheath that was his body just fell away revealing a body made purely of light.
As the sheath fell away like a lightweight Halloween costume,
he stepped out of his skin to stand as the new light being who said to him,
I'll Ms. Scott.
He was really fun.
I was confused by that and a bit frightened.
It sounded as if Scott was not long for this world.
Was He going to die?
Scott didn't really seem very concerned about it,
so I didn't say anything about the questions that brought up in me.
He seemed deeply touched by the experience.
It was amazing.
Over the years since that trip to India,
I would flash back on Scott's experience in the Jain temple and I often wondered
if he did too.
If he relived the words,
I'll Ms. Scott.
He was really fun.
Now I know each of did revisit that experience many times and now those words
have a different significance to me.
I had taken the experience then as a spiritual experience where Scott was
becoming less attached to the physical world and identifying more with his
universal self.
Yes,
he was less attached to the physical but not necessarily for spiritual reasons.
This was real physical,
uh,
direct hotline to who he was.
He was less attached to his body because he never felt he belonged in it.
He probably felt like unzipping it and stepping out of it most of the time.
And yet he might have to stay in Cayston that ill fitting costume for the rest
of his life.
So you've had a little glimpse into my personal history.
As I said,
there's more in the book,
some,
um,
some fun stories.
This isn't all scary stuff.
Um,
though transgender has been around for centuries,
it really,
as I said,
has not been talked about very much until more recently.
And as people have talked about it and come out some of the names,
you know,
I'll let you fill in the blanks,
um,
and covered by the media.
Um,
one of,
one of my earliest experiences of this was when I was watching an Oprah show.
And Oprah had on a couple where one of the two had transgendered and they,
um,
the couple was staying together.
They were beautiful.
Couple happily married.
They had kids.
Um,
the,
the one who had been a,
a husband was a doctor and was maintaining now her practice.
She was gorgeous by the way.
And they talked about their whole experience.
And I swear to God,
I looked at the television and said out loud,
well,
at least I'll never have to deal with that.
So I want to be sharing this with you because that's an example of how far I've
had to come.
That was my feeling about what transgender was at the time.
So suffice to say,
it's been quite an arc.
My life has been an arc of discovery,
of questioning until I could find peace and understanding and love.
I talk about all the phases that I went through.
And I think that the phases of loss anyway for a lot of people,
you know,
I,
I went through denial,
um,
fears,
ultimatums.
Okay,
you can do this as long as you don't do that.
Okay?
You can pierce years and grow your hair,
but no way are you going to wear dresses.
And at the time Scotty would say that that's okay,
that's enough.
I don't really want more.
Um,
but obviously for a lot of trans people,
they're not really complete with their journey until they even go all the way
through the point of having surgery and having the body that be speaks to
gender,
they identify with.
Um,
I was so determined that this was just maybe a phase or midlife crisis.
In fact,
when Scotty came downstairs to say to me that early morning with the two cups of
coffee and just blurted out the first word,
she said,
we're,
I don't know who I am.
And so my first thought was,
oh God,
midlife crisis,
you're going to want to Porsche.
And it's suffice to say that as the journey progressed,
I was kind of wishing it had been the desire for a Porsche.
I had bouts where I played Nancy drew,
I'll get back to that in a minute,
but I also
since Scotty to our homeopaths to get a remedy
cause I thought,
you know,
there's just some kind of mix up in the system.
All she needs is rebalancing of some kind.
And to her credit,
she went,
I'm sure rolling her proverbial eyes in her head the whole way.
But she was willing to do that for me.
So all of my steps were baby steps towards acceptance.
Now I don't know if any of you grew up with Nancy drew.
Nancy drew was a series of,
uh,
detective books about a young woman who was a detective.
Um,
they've been upgraded even over the years because they were very famous popular
series.
And I think now Nancy probably does drive a Porsche at the time she drove a
roadster.
So you're just going to have to Google that and figure out how that old car
looked.
But that I started snooping around.
I couldn't stand the feeling that there was a secret.
And even those Scotty had come out to me.
I didn't understand what transgender was.
I started researching,
which actually was kind of a mistake because as you of all people probably know,
a lot of the things you can find on the Internet are disturbing.
You can find very disturbing stories.
So I thought,
well,
this isn't where I want to be.
So I admit I would go into Scotty's computer and look for clues.
And so I became quite the detective,
um,
and it was pretty good at it actually.
Uh,
I surprised myself at how good I was at finding phone numbers that were coded,
things like that.
So,
um,
I don't know if you can say that,
you know,
someone who's transgender,
uh,
whether you have a family member or a friend.
Um,
but now that you've met Scotty,
you can no longer say you don't know someone who's transgender.
And I don't know if there's any questions that we can check in to see if
anyone's asked questions,
if not,
um,
the,
so no questions on the dory,
but this is a good time to remind people who are listening on livestream.
If you have questions,
please be sure to write them in the Dory and we'll get back to them in a few.
Great.
Thank you,
Monica.
Um,
part of the reason I say that is because,
um,
Scotty and I are making a real point to getting out and about.
We've spoken at universities and other corporations and,
um,
Lgbtq organizations.
I Aa plus,
um,
because we really want our lives to be an open book.
We want us to be the people that you can count on to ask questions of where no
one will be upset by the question.
No one will feel
shamed or hurt by a question because we really want people to be educated about
this.
Um,
when I've run into any kind of resistance or bumps with people,
I really find it's because people don't really understand.
One of the biggest signs of that is somebody might say,
why would you choose to be a woman?
And a lot of my women friends will say that,
who would want to choose to be a woman?
Um,
but it's,
it's not a matter of choice.
And I think that's one of the biggest things that's really important to say.
Okay.
Um,
people ask me why and how I did it.
So
a big part of what I had to do was look through my own concepts.
What is a husband?
What is a wife?
What is marriage?
What is love?
What is gender?
I mean,
heck,
I'd already been mis-gendered as a lesbian or years before.
So what's in a word?
And I,
I dug deeply into those words,
but my relationship with them,
what did I think love was and what did I think a husband was?
Um,
you know,
as my mate and my spouse and my beloved Scotty was fulfilling those things that
we really look for most in a relationship.
So I thought,
well,
does it matter that I call this person my husband or do I have love?
And I kept thinking how I had looked for love,
okay.
In all the wrong places.
I'd look for love for a long time until I found Scotty.
And I also thought about all the ways that,
that she had stuck with me,
that she had really been generous.
She's a great cook,
which really helps.
Um,
but took good care of me all along the way was loving,
was the love I'd always looked for when I was diagnosed with ovarian cancer.
She didn't run away.
She took care of me and went with the doctor to me and has always supported me
throughout the whole process.
So looking at the words that we have and re asking ourselves,
how do I relate to that?
Um,
how do I relate to the things that my parents or peers or teachers taught me
back when?
Um,
it's really a valuable thing to do.
And we've often played a game with people when we've talked to it's,
we call it the binary game and ask people to say some of the things that,
um,
maybe they were taught or was said to them when they were little or even now
that has affected their opinion of something.
And even with the young people in the universities,
it's amazing how much those kinds of messages are still being given to them.
You know,
Scotty will often share how,
um,
her dad would say to Scott,
you run like a girl
or if you're,
if you're going to cry like that Mary Jane go put on a dress.
Yes.
So first of all,
that's a double whammy of putting a woman down,
but also telling your son that he's less than by saying he's like a girl.
Um,
my mother really screwed me up because she,
um,
wanted me to not like drive like a girl or throw a ball like a girl,
but so she was the one who had to teach me how to do that.
So that's kind of confusing.
Did you have something,
Monica?
Yeah,
there's a question on the dory and it's,
um,
relevant to how you're speaking about these questions that you're asking
yourselves,
um,
around binary and what,
what that means.
So the question is,
um,
how did you feel about the impact on your own identity?
Um,
you know,
given that you were,
part of a binary at,
you know,
a woman,
um,
w when did you decide to continue to be with your trans partner?
Did you feel your identity was being erased?
Oh,
just a light question.
Um,
I,
it did occur to me that I would maybe leave,
I think it was a knee jerk reaction.
Like,
well,
I can't be here.
I'm not a lesbian.
I can't be with this person.
Um,
but again,
by evaluating some of those things,
we'll wait a minute.
Who is this person?
Um,
I had to really think about that and I'll get to the eraser part in a minute
cause I do have an answer about that too.
But,
um,
one of the biggest words I really had to look at was commitment because I'd
already been in marriages where basically I gave up on the commitment or someone
gave up on me.
So what does commitment,
I mean in our vows we say till death do us part.
Um,
so,
and I started looking at other couples who have stayed together like Michael Fox
and um,
uh,
Christopher Reeves and you know,
stuff happens in life and stuff happens to your partner.
So do you walk away?
So as I said,
Scotty hadn't walked away from me when I got deathly ill diagnosis.
So I'm looking at commitment was one thing.
Um,
yes,
it made me question a lot about me and me as a woman at first.
Um,
and I used to sometimes to tease that.
Well now I'm the one who wears the pants in the family,
the Scott,
he's very into feminine stuff and I wasn't,
I was a tomboy.
So,
uh,
yes,
it made me question my own identity as a woman.
Um,
another sidebar was because Scotty was getting so much attention,
uh,
I started to ask the question,
what am I chopped liver.
I felt it was more like I just pushed,
I felt pushed aside a bit as a person.
Um
hmm.
Couple of things that helped me get through that was Scottie herself because,
and,
and I want to say this because sometimes you'll hear,
uh,
that,
that trans people are selfish and I think especially if they come later in age,
they come out later in age.
They,
they just want their life.
They've put it off for long enough.
Dammit.
I want to be who I am.
Scotty was very generous and patient with me and I could beat on her chest and
scream and cry and accuse,
how could you do this to me?
How could you lie to me this long?
Um,
and,
but learn because she was patient and we talked about everything.
We worked it all out together.
Um,
that she wasn't lying to me,
that actually she was the opposite of being.
She had,
um,
pretended to be a man for all that time so that she wouldn't hurt me.
So,
um,
okay.
The other side of that is our friends,
thank God the,
the friends that we have in the family that we have in our lives,
um,
didn't allow me to be chopped liver for too long because pretty much as soon as
they would hear the news,
the next question would be turning to me and go,
how are you?
So I was included.
They knew that this might be hard for me and I felt that they were there to
support me.
And I have a couple of funny stories about friends too,
but it sounds like it.
That was certainly one of the questions I asked you.
How are you?
Right.
And I'm glad you're doing well.
Um,
that was,
uh,
another question that has come up.
Actually two questions.
Um,
one is how has your network of family and friends changed over time?
Uh,
and,
uh,
a question that I actually had to just out of curiosity,
what in your day to day has changed?
Like what's different in your day to day life and your relationship with Scotty?
Wow,
okay.
You may need to remind me of some cells,
so,
sure.
Um,
well family and friends.
So this is maybe a good place for me to tell a couple of my friends' stories
because I realized too,
one of my biggest fears was telling people like,
are they going to be shocked?
Are they going to think we're weird?
Obviously they think we're queer and now that I know what queer means,
but,
um,
I really was afraid of people's reaction and that we might be shunned and
rejected.
And,
um,
so I took give these two examples in the book to a dear friend Melissa,
who had worked with for a really long time.
I waited,
I didn't want to tell people for a really long time,
I think because I kept hoping that Scotty would suddenly wake up someday and it
would,
oh my God,
I don't know what I was thinking.
I'm your husband again,
but that never came.
So,
um,
I,
I was feeling quite alone for a long time and uh,
I told my friend Melissa,
who was there to visit,
I said,
you know what?
I have something to tell you.
And she went,
what?
Oh,
I said,
well,
Scott,
he's a woman.
And she said,
Oh,
thank God.
I thought you were going to say you were splitting up
and that instantly it did something inside my whole being like this wasn't a bad
thing that that's Scotty was,
was trans.
The bad thing was this love story that so many of our friends had subscribed to
and looked up to and wanted to clone my husband to have one of their own like
him.
That's what mattered to them was our love and preserving that.
So the other one was,
um,
I was sharing with a friend who is a lesbian,
uh,
of our childhood crushes.
And I had a mad crush on Richard Chamberlain who played Dr Kildare and a TV
series way back when,
I think TV was still black and white,
but I just had the biggest crush on him.
And she said,
oh,
really?
My crush was Hayley mills.
So,
um,
I said,
yeah,
I know,
but then I find out that that Richard Chamberlain is,
is gay.
And she goes,
yeah.
And you ended up with Hayley Mills.
It's nice.
Oh,
and so the biggest change day to day in your life and your relationship with
Scotty?
I'm more into makeup now because I have someone who can teach me.
I really saw how much I was a tomboy and I shunned makeup and Scotty was so into
it.
At first it really bugged me,
but,
um,
but then I would watch her put it on and they go,
Oh,
where'd you get that color?
Or,
so,
uh,
makeup is a day to day change.
MMM.
I think part of it is also my priorities have changed.
Some of that has been with a diagnosis that I got,
but,
um,
yeah,
I'm relying a lot on my humor.
I are,
I always did.
But I think that was also one of the things that got me through and seeing the
synchronicity and everything that happens around me and how sometimes things are
almost a joke by the universe or a perfect pun on life itself.
Um,
I'm,
hello,
I'm now less resistant to being affectionate in public with Scotty.
Uh,
I was at first like,
Oh,
don't kiss me.
don't hold my hand and now I'll be the one to reach for her hand or,
or give her a kiss.
So,
because you know what,
I don't care.
Um,
my relationship even to the word lesbian,
like I was worried that people would think I'm a lesbian because now I was with
a woman.
But of course I flashed back on my high school days and went,
hmm,
okay,
that's interesting.
Um,
but I don't need a label.
People kind of want to put you in a box and name it something.
And,
um,
I don't have to be,
be a lesbian to be in love with my spouse
just because she's a woman.
Nice.
Um,
are there any questions here in the audience?
Yes,
my friend hers.
Thank you.
So Marcy,
my question is,
um,
are,
are there any,
I mean there's so many spiritual aspects to what you've just described,
but are there any other lessons that
were particularly powerful?
Few from a kind of spiritual point of view about what's happened?
Yeah,
thank you.
Great question.
Um,
I think
contemplation was an important one and contemplating words and,
and does this resonate with me?
Do I need to accept this word anymore in my vocabulary?
But one of the things that released to me,
I think the most is that,
um,
I believe in Karma.
Uh,
and,
and not kind of the everyday variety,
the way some people slinging it around.
I mean,
I really do believe that,
um,
what goes around comes around and that everything in one's life is a result of
past behaviors,
thoughts,
beliefs,
actions.
So once I kind of had this Aha that
Scotty didn't do this to me,
I was in this situation because it was my Karma to be in this situation.
I might not exactly see the reason why,
but I was supposed to be here and that erased the blame wasn't Scotty's fault.
Scotty wasn't doing this to me.
I was supposed to be here.
So now what are you going to do with it?
And um,
it was actually Scott Scott,
he's dad who had a saying that became my,
my guiding light through all the rest of my process,
which kind of has to do with that.
And Jim Madden used to say,
you can go sitting up in the saddle or strapped across it,
but you're going riding Jesse James.
Nice.
Good.
So we have another question in the audience.
Hi.
Hi,
I'm Marcy.
Um,
I just want to ask,
how did you guys first meet and how long did you date before he got married?
Ah,
we first met when we were both working for a production company in San Diego.
Um,
apparently when Scotty saw me,
is this fair to say
it was love at first sight?
I had this little stumbling block as I think I've told you that I was married at
the time.
Um,
but Scotty and I struck up this great friendship and we'd have great
philosophical talks.
Um,
and I think this is one thing that was important and I would actually offer as
advice about relationships,
is that friendship is really a key core important ingredient.
So we were friends first and we'd have arguments about Karma and philosophical
things like that.
And I will also admit that Scotty's quite a bit younger than,
than I.
So I thought I was going to,
cause this guy was so great,
fix him up with my stepdaughter and she was on the um,
the cheer team for uh,
she was going to Oregon state and her team was coming down the basketball team
to play at,
um,
Ucla.
So I since her,
she was going to come as a cheer girl.
I invited Scotty Scott to come with me and bill and come meet Kelly and the
whole drive up from San Diego to La.
All Scott did was talk about these flipping earrings that he made for this other
woman that he was interested in and they were Yin Yang.
And I remember sitting in the front seat next to my then husband and literally
said to myself,
I was,
somebody loves me like that.
And after my marriage ended and I had had a few months and Scotty had had an
experience where,
um,
she was meditating one day and said that she saw me,
and this had been months and months since we'd worked together.
Um,
she called and said,
I haven't experienced,
I want to share with you.
And came to visit.
We went for a walk and I just fell in love with this being on the walk and she
basically never left after that.
So it sounds like you're,
um,
marriage and relationship has both moved through chant,
transgender and has also transcended,
transcended any kinds of labels or boxes or a naming of,
of any kind.
And that's really inspiring.
Um,
in this time,
um,
I want to thank you,
and thank you,
Scotty,
for coming to Google and sharing your story and being human with us about,
um,
about how we can love in any circumstance.
So thank you.
Thank you.